last year the homie chad
he kicked the 60 yard field goal
[Music]
today he thinks he can out kick the nfl
kicker
we bought the seat
[Music]
we brought in an actual nfl kicker eddie
pinero eddie yeah do you think you could
be eddie in the kicking competition
can't eddie beat me in the kicking
competition because the pressure's on
him absolutely not he's acting like i
didn't kick in the league like what are
you saying
what are you saying james you know why i
can kick an nfl right now bro for dinner
last night you had a piece of cake and a
mountain dew look at my quads huh they
do the talking sign what is wrong with
you 500 all the way around i got 500 on
chat against you i got 500 on chat
against you
[Music]
let me see it
he's got a venmo you we already been
over this where's my wallet 85 are you
ready
are you going to stretch i don't stretch
you're not even going to stretch i don't
stretch there's no there's a hammy
[Music]
a little warm up don't think about it
huh
[Applause]
everybody watch greatness right here
greatness hey
okay okay let's back it
[Music]
there you go up just think about it a
little bit hey get out of my kicker's
head man just let him let him do his
thing he's a professional
and that's a professional field goal
baby
watch the greatness right here
that's in there
piece of cake here just the 50-yarder
eddie do not think about it why laugh
why left my lap
i want
all righty three
two
one time out time out time
[Music]
all right we are at 60. we're at 60
watch a professional work watch them
work
yes sir
well you cleared that
boy let's go let's go
oh my goodness
oh
my god
we made it it's good
you don't understand the twerk that i'm
having to use here
yeah your car
torque cork
there it is
[Music]
in the head-to-head matchup our guy
eddie pinero came through made you some
money made you some money made you some
money thank you sir thank you sir i need
my 500 immediately this is the thing he
understands the power behind what
the quad